peace be with you welcome to the Dean
show another exciting show before we get
started I got to show you this clip I
got to show you this clip watch this
my next guest is on the forefront
combating ignorance racism like what
you've just seen educating people
he's been on CNN Fox News and all the
major networks my next guest from Kerr
the director of care Chicago we'll be
right back with him here in additional
don't go anywhere
this is the thing
this is the beam you know this is the
thing this is the with you how are you
very well thank you peace be on to you
as well how you been I've been well we
had about rehab yes director of care
Chicago yes now we started the program
you guys are doing some wonderful work I
mentioned you're on the forefront of
tackling bigotry racism you know helping
to defend the civil liberties of the
American citizens who live in this
country and particularly those now who
are coming under attack we just got to
see this video very sad it's very sad
reality of what's going on out there and
a lot of ignorance what are you what are
your we're gonna show it one more time
- you know it's physical assault it's
illegal but what the mindset behind the
assault is hatred this individual
obviously looks at this woman and thinks
you know I can slap her I can punch her
there isn't going to be major you know
major reaction because she doesn't count
for much this sort of marginalization
this sort of you know hatred and bigotry
that we see many Muslims be subjected to
unfortunately especially in a post-911
you know climate is exactly what we're
trying to fight against and I'm one of
many people who are fighting the right
fight or trying to write a fight the
right fight in order to bring attention
to the fact that all human beings should
be treated with respect and dignity and
then America under our Constitution all
citizens are entitled to the same rights
whether they're Muslim or Christian or
Jews whether the black or white men or
women it's the same Constitution with
the same civil rights for everybody and
that's not something you just made off
at the top of your head this is what
islam teaches this is what we learned
from when we studied this way of life
that we live a way of life a piece of
mercy of tolerance this is what it's
about
absolutely you know one of the most
important elements and really
cornerstones of Shetty on again this
word you know it's the SH word it's the
word that everybody's afraid of but
really all it means is law and we talk
when we talk about Sharia in the context
of Islam we talk about Islamic law and
in that we're not talking about some
kind of repressive you know force
something on someone but rather when you
buy into Islam as an individual and it's
out of your free will and choice you are
then bound by certain laws the laws of
God and the first cornerstone is freedom
meaning the freedom to choose you have
free will
you know Islam cannot be imposed upon
you it cannot be something that is you
know there's no compulsion no compulsion
if they gonna have a deal like Crawford
Dean one of the cornerstones of Islam
and so that's the first things that you
come to it by choice the second is
dignity human dignity
Karam allaha wa jal insane Allah subhana
WA Ta'ala has made unique and dignified
and enlightened the face of mankind the
face of humanity the face of man and
now you said something in Arabic now
there's a lot of you know people who
don't understand the Arabic language you
said this word Allah and some people
already you said Sharia and I can't we
equate this to the Ten Commandments
Moses came with a Sharia Jesus came I
mean to confirm the Sharia this is
simply like you said God's law well yeah
absolutely but we also have to be smart
enough and he wants to enough to
understand that there are Muslims out
there who are part of the problem in
that they put forth a very rigid
structure yes that isn't necessarily out
of each man meaning out of a consensus
of the Muslim ulema muslim scholars and
it used it tends to be on the far right
and that is what scares many people and
it's not just extreme and intense in its
interpretation but it's forceful and its
implementation and that is what creates
the sharia scare coming out of parts of
the Middle East and South Asia and
emanating into the West
you said Allah for the people out there
they turn an end they've they think like
a large some moon guy you know what is
this just a god of the Muslims well you
know Jesus being a Semite Moses being a
Semite both of them being from the
Middle East chances are they refer to
God using the word Allah or a derivative
of a la lengua stick derivative eel or
something like that Aloha and probably
not God which is actually a word out of
northern Europe yeah so Allah again just
means God my god that's the same God
that Jesus worship Abraham Moses the one
God who created this whole universe and
everything in it and Aramaic you
mentioned that you know Jesus didn't
speak English and I've looked this up
you can look this up he would say Aloha
exactly and you know it's funny because
just taking onto Jesus example moving
forward when we have issues and
instances of racial profiling and there
are many people in America today that
actually argue for racial profiling
saying that look it's the middle eastern
guys who commit all the trouble why
would we go after the you know Swedish
grandma and you know one of the things
that comes to mind and usually an
argument I give back is that if Jesus
himself was to try to get into JFK
Airport or a hare Airport per your own
standards you probably detained him for
hours because any light you'd likely
olive-skinned you know with bushy black
hair probably wearing a Jill Bob you
know
we're showing a picture right now of
what is betrayed of Jesus obviously not
him but what people betray of them
exactly what you're saying right and we
all know Jesus is not and was not a
terrorist and likewise so are most
Muslims not terrorists so it's not you
cannot profile you know racially or
phenotypically you know the outside
appearance of someone and say that
that's the only thing we need to look at
or the main thing we need to look at to
identify this person as a potential
problem
rather it is behavior it is track record
it is hard intelligence and really you
know law enforcement cannot escape the
fact that their job is to look for raw
data you know hard intelligence and then
go after the trail where there's smoke
there's fire potentially but not just
after somebody's looks or somebody's
religion or somebody's skin color we
know that Jesus I mean no Muslim is a
Muslim unless you believe and love Jesus
you can't be a Muslim one who submits to
the will of God I said Muslim is unless
you love Jesus and we love Jesus and
Jesus promoted love so where's all this
hate you know because if you read the
Bible says love your love your enemies
you know love your neighbors so we're
the Muslim is your neighbor your doctor
your dentist so where's all this I mean
this is not coming from Jesus all this
hate was coming from you know it's
coming from the inner darkness of
humanity the same place where goodness
comes out of you know the inside of
humanity you know it the soul Allah
Subhan Allah Tala
God be blessed and Almighty you know
explained to us through his Deen through
Islam that he created mankind with a
soul this soul has been given the
capacity to do good and the capacity to
do evil it was not ordained as evil or
ordained as good it had the capacity for
both now which one you end up being
depends on what you choose for yourself
in this dunya in this life and those who
purify their souls end up committing
acts of good being good and those who
contaminate their souls end up being you
know evil and committing evil so it's
your choice and God gives you the the
freedom to choose which direction you
take and that's what life is all about
so it's the same place evil and goodness
it's not you know the brown bird the
light are bad that black are good the
so it's not by race it's not by nation
it's not even by religion it's by the
human soul the goodness and evil is
decided and you know the major war it's
not World War one or World War two it's
not the Iraq war it's not World War
three god forbid it ever happens it's
the war inside each and every one of us
and if that war is won with the right
victor and that is the good soul the
goodness of the soul then there will be
peace on earth now we know that the Jews
were persecuted at one point the
Japanese you had the african-americans
is this just the Muslims turn now you
know that argument has been made and
there's truth to that
you know the growing pains of being a
new immigrant population in America and
I'd have to pause here and say that
Muslims are very diverse they're not
monolithic and a good percentage of
Muslims in America are not immigrants at
least new immigrants you know they've
been here for hundreds of years
African Americans and other communities
that have come hundreds of years ago but
the majority of the Muslim community in
America as a young transnational
immigrant community and yes it is
growing pains we've seen this sort of
bigotry and discrimination that targets
a group happened with Italians with Jews
with Germans in the past with Dutch with
the Japanese with Latinos you know
extending it to now and Muslims
unfortunately like everybody else is
going through this and it's high time
that we learn from our history and stop
repeating the same mistakes and you know
we're going through this now we're going
to come out on top like everybody else
did and I hope that we as Muslims stand
against this happening to anybody else
even if they're not Muslim whether it be
the Buddhists or Hindus or any other
people we as Muslims stand for equality
you know goodness civil rights for all
not just for Muslims have you seen I
mean you are at the forefront and we
know people we've discussed this on to
do so many time we've had scholars come
on and condemn such acts as 9/11 the
Boston bombing you know horrific acts
against innocent civilians that have
happened so now why is it that usually
you know the the layman they're like why
don't Muslim speak out against these
acts is the media being fair and
bringing on people you know they'll
bring on people who have voice their
opinion
you know strongly against Muslims Islam
but now on the other end you know our is
our voice strong enough because I can
testify we've had dozens of people come
on and condemn such evil acts what is
your opinion being on the fourth oh well
I think condemnation is have been plenty
and they've been wide and deep and many
who say that they don't hear them simply
don't go to the places where they need
to hear them and you know I've been
asked before in speeches in conferences
on TV you know why don't lose limbs
condemn this and that and I asked the
person I'm a Muslim sitting in front of
you I've actually condemned the very
thing of which you speak now now my
question to you did you go to my website
no did you read any of my articles no
well then how do you expect me to let
you know that I'm condemning this the
expect a personal email a leaflet that I
should drop off in your mailbox at home
I mean if you don't do the effort you
can't really come and complain and say
Muslims are not doing but having said
that my concern is a Muslim it's not so
much about doing the condemnation dance
but rather fixing our own house we need
to do more as an Ummah we may be doing
all right in the United States
relatively speaking but as an Ummah
around the world of Muslims together
there are many many things we need to
work on we are not in a good place we
need to be in a much better place in
terms of our understanding of our own
Deen our application of this Deen and
keeping out the extremes on both sides
the extreme far rebel liberal and
extreme far you know right-wing groups
that contaminate not just the image of
this Deen but the way we live it on a
daily basis
beautiful going to take a break and for
many people you know this is probably
probably the only exposure they have to
Islam to the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon them so we're gonna end with this
we're going to come back but you know
God the Prophet peace be upon him said
show mercy to those on earth and God
will show you mercy so this is not again
what I said something we're making up
Islam is deep a merciful way of life and
we'll be back to have some more time
here spent with our guests Ahmed here on
the Deen show I'm so tired
when I read through the Old Testament
the New Testament it didn't make any
sense
feels like a walk a thousand miles when
I looked into the eastern faiths such as
our Hinduism and Buddhism and Taoism of
whatnot uninspired done yeah got me on
money I agree with a lot of the
principles and ideas the same
Christianity and Judaism but they just
didn't strike a chord they didn't make
sense of but thankfully you've got Islam
oh and as a result of such I was not a
fan of religion was not a fan of
organized religion and I took a very
atheist approach towards belief it gets
me through trying times oh I could leave
work go have a bottle of vodka smoke a
pack of cigarettes have a double bacon
and double cheese sandwich and go to
sleep drunk and happy he'd come to work
the next day and I was miserable and
when I read the no book going on Oh what
do you think about Christ what do you
think about God who is Allah who is
Muhammad it tells me what's the truth
and give me the proof was there
something a little bit of intelligence
and a little bit of Investigation you
can see that this time is not the
boogeyman that has been laid out my
yellow light is the one the one the one
one the one I didn't believe in
organized religion at all
to read the Quran I thought to myself
here's another book I can put on the
shelf of fictitious make leave the whole
the Lola took me three nights to read
the Quran and when I was done reading it
I remember thinking when it was the
first and to the state the only
religious book I've ever read that makes
sense
from beginning to end it doesn't
contradict itself it's an instruction
for the Mayans the
back here on the Dean show with the
director of care Chicago and tell us I'm
it that you've been on almost all the
major networks CNN Fox News which one's
your favorite I personally enjoy doing
the right-wing shows because there's
more intensity to them it's more
interesting for me I also like doing NPR
and you know some of the more reasonable
media but there's not much of a
challenge there and I enjoy being
challenged so I really like doing Fox
News for example you enjoy I'm really
surprised that they even have you on Fox
News I mean usually they bring somebody
who has some twisted views about Islam
whose actually doesn't speak any English
and doesn't really portray Islam in the
right way as far as you know being a
voice and can't answer the questions
properly so you know when they bring you
on it's it's also really a shock and why
don't they bring on credible you know
also along with you scholars people who
dedicated their life who are Americans
hear from I know they bring on Ibrahim
occasionally but why do you think they
do is this intentionally I think part of
it is I mean Fox News is not exactly an
unbiased source of news it does have an
agenda it does have a worldview and the
way they choose their guests for the
most part the segments that they cover
the kind of things that they say the
angle in the show is pretty much
informed and fed by that worldview you
know I don't feel that they bring me on
by choice most of the time I don't feel
on the first choice I feel that you know
when they run out of options
and I'm readily available you know
waving my hand and ready to come on
you know then they bring me on or if
it's something very much up my alley and
they have really no choice but I would
wish to that you know we could do this
more often because it's an opportunity
for me to reach out across the aisle and
I'm not really addressing the anchor
whether it's O'Reilly or Hannity or
somebody else I'm really reaching out to
the audiences at home people who don't
hear from Muslims too often people who
watch Fox News in the red states who
don't have Muslim neighbors possibly who
may have biased views of Islam you know
it's an opportunity for us to show our
humanity our intellect and make our
arguments even if you don't agree then
at least we're breaking stereotypes in
the way we're speaking and in what we're
speaking about in how we're speaking I
want to go to another clip and I get
your thoughts on this John Jameson's
actions are under evaluation by count
administrator Robert Wiseman today who
told us he is pursuing the possibility
of disciplinary action for the comments
that Jameson made on his personal
Facebook page there is no such thing as
radical Islam all Islam is radical the
Quran is a book that preaches hate you
got to see this clip now he didn't just
say you know it's not you know they've
some have separated so there's radical
Islam he said no no no no he was like
all Islam is radical and this Quran is
you know preaching hate and violence and
this is someone who's in public office
do you deal a lot with people like this
yes because what we're facing is a
cottage industry what that means is
there's a niche industry that has
developed again mostly after 9/11 but
going as far back in its origins as the
medieval times as the Crusades in that
and today they're becoming more
sophisticated in their organizing and
disseminating of information but they
remain very primitive and their talking
points and their narratives one of the
narratives is Islam itself is violence
it isn't the extreme it isn't the fringe
it's the mainstream it's the Quran
itself it's their Prophet Mohammed who
was a pedophile who was a murderer who
was a rapist who was crazy a lunatic bla
bla bla bla bla they go to the core of
the religion and start to vilify and
demonize the religion and as such by
extension essentially vilifying the 2
billion Muslims around the world and
that's obviously something that we stand
very much against we dissect
intellectually to show the problems with
the logic the the the falsehood in the
allegations historically and in
contemporary terms but more importantly
to be a zombie present as the other side
on TV in newspapers on the radio to
bring our message out as strong if
that's stronger to be able to defeat the
lies that are being spread by these
people and it usually starts on the
internet so we have a strong internet
presence to you know address this at its
core I want to shift the blame on us a
little bit because I feel confident I
feel confident
I mean God Almighty the crater's the one
who changes the hearts but I feel
confident if I was to sit with someone
like this someone who had these views
and I had some lunch with them maybe
brought them down to my academy dojo and
I did some Jitsu when I'm throw them
around you
wrapped them up a little like a pretzel
all in a matter of fun at the end had a
really civilized conversation you know
maybe he'd even accept Islam because
it's all about worshiping the creator
not the creation doing good being good
and being the best that you can be so
you can paint paradise in the next life
and and and then or he would walk away
being a friend because he'd understand
that all these crazy beliefs were just
based on lies and ignorance and I think
if many of us were out there sharing the
purpose of life sharing truly what Islam
is about that a lot of these walls would
be knocked down what do you views on
earth I agree I mean a big part of it is
representation and the most important
part is self representation and where we
fail to do that others fill in the
vacuum with their own you know very
warped views of who we are and that's
why we're in media that's why we're in
schools that's why we're dealing with
neighbors and with communities and
churches or with government we're coming
out of what used to be you know the
shadows for us as a community and
becoming more civically engaged you hear
this word a lot civic engagement to
bring out our voices and our humanity to
the fore so people can know what we're
about and what a religion is about let
me just be clear that from care
Chicago's perspective and cares
perspective we're not trying to have
people accept Islam that's not our job
we're not a dowel
organization we're simply trying to
fight what we consider to be very
backward very unsophisticated and very
primitive views on who Muslims are which
we believe is not just hurtful to
Muslims but very hurtful to America and
to the person who holds these views you
know I always say this hatred is a
self-addressed envelope you put it in
the mail box it's gonna come right back
to your home gonna hurt you more
definitely hurts you more than it hurts
me
yes it's like holding a weapon in a war
and before you can fire at your opponent
the weight of the of the weapon you know
varies you that's what hate is all about
and so hatred is not just something that
threatens us but it's really a threat to
society as a whole
definitely it's like drinking poison and
waiting for your enemy to die exactly
look at this quote from the last the
Federal Minister sent to mankind peace
be upon him eat your thoughts and he
said be kind for whatever kindness
becomes a part of something it
beautifies it
and whenever it is taken away from sunny
it leaves it tarnished and I mentioned
another quote you know show mercy if you
want mercy from the Creator before we
left out again you know there are I mean
so someone is probably like look you're
showing all of this now for good PR but
we know how do you tackle when we show
this the people get a different
perspective that Islam is about love
it's about mercy
Islam is L AM Islam says love all
mankind and we truly love all mankind
that's why we're trying to share this
message of peace with the world purpose
so now you just read this do people get
to see this do they get did they get to
see you know these beautiful statements
from the last different of messages sent
to mankind apart Muhammad peace be upon
them
no they don't we recently met with a
German delegation of from law
enforcement the police in Germany and
they talked about how they have these
outreach campaigns with Muslims in their
cities where they play basketball and
try to be their friends in hopes to
prevent them from becoming terrorists or
extremists or radicals and the question
I posed to them was you know that's not
the job of law enforcement you're
supposed to look for crime you're not
supposed to deal with the entire
community as a potential criminal this
is like you know the FBI or the Chicago
Police going to make friends with Fabio
and Alfonso and you know Dimitri arsons
thinking you know this way they're not
gonna join the mob one day so the
problem is before you understand what is
wrong with a community you have to
understand what's right and law
enforcement the media many other sources
or many other consumers of information
about Islam fail to know the normative
Islam failed to know you and your wife
and your family and me and my family and
how we live as Muslims they only are
looking at unfortunately most of the
time the underwear bomber you know the
19 guys from 9/11 the guys they see on
TV waving weapons and you know yelling
into the camera and they start there and
from there they begin to try to
understand Islam as a religion that's
like having vowels you want to one be
about cancer cells before you understand
that there's a skeleton there's a
muscular you know a system to the body
there's a digestive system you know the
normative body before you understand all
of that which all kids study in biology
you know early biology you go straight
into the cancerous cells in hopes to
understand the whole human
it doesn't work that way and so yes
there is an impetus and an imperative on
the mainstream and we have to help them
it's our role to do so to know the
normative Islam the mainstream Islam the
daily Islam not just in America but
around the world and it's peaceful it's
loving it's family-oriented it's not
much different from what they would want
for their own families and then from
there to know what's wrong with you know
those who are doing bad things which
we're more than happy to admit that we
have bad apples
you know like anybody else and we're
dealing with that and we're not ashamed
or not embarrassed or not in denial of
the fact that there are problems much
like any other community but you got to
begin from understanding the mainstream
and separating that and your perception
of that from dealing with the problem I
so we showed the individual who made
these statements we got to go to break
before before we go to break we showed a
statement from the last of my dementia
prime Muhammad about kindness about
mercy let's go to the verbatim Word of
God before we go to break this is so
deep listen to this worship no one other
than God be good to your parents and
relatives and to those and to the
orphans and the poor
speak kindly to everyone establish
prayer and giving charity I mean how can
you object to that it's something
beautiful it's something wonderful and
we take strong perception when you call
this book you know a book of evil it's a
book from the Creator that happens an
earth that cause people to goodness
nothing but good there's so much love in
it read it read it read it
we'll be right back with more with our
brother Hamid here on the Dean show I
started asking deeper questions the
question I want people to really ask
themselves is when you come back from a
night on the town
you've been drinking you've been boozing
you've been dancing
hanging out with girls guys whatever
number one did you improve yourself as
human being number two did you
contribute anything to the betterment of
humanity the amazing thing is is that
the most advanced studies in psychology
about human happiness show that these
are the two key factors in making people
profoundly happy I take five minutes out
of my day and prayed to the Creator and
none of the creations and I feel a deep
internal peace and I still have my
normal life fiction somehow the idea got
into their minds that to kill other
people is a great thing to do and that
they would be rewarded in the here but
Christians do that every single day in
this country do they blow people up yes
all of the Christians everyday people
walk into post off I mean people walk
into post offices they walk into schools
that's what Columbine is I mean I could
do this all day long there's so there's
so many more examples of Christians and
I happen to be a Christian that's back
to this notion of you're idealizing
Christianity in my mind to my read
there's so many more examples ayianna of
Christians who do that then you could
ever give me examples of Muslims who
have done it inside this country where
you even work it's killing of innocent
human beings human life is precious if
you have a Facebook guys I never ask a
man for help can I ask a lot can
Facebook make sure you like our statuses
and think about deaths was--they on our
own you never know that one person they
shared one of our videos too and when no
one's looking you sneak and gives the
cop you never know that person might
change and end up becoming listen and
you can reap the rewards if everything
that person have learned has learned
from your share you watch to work but
you late for salat a Muslim never brags
what does actions say a lot like us like
Facebook Twitter and follow us on
Twitter and one last thing you want a
piece of the profit but not peace for
the prophecy that money is your Lord
your worship the logic gulfs is fine if
you have less YouTube subscribe though
the tab or Quran you learn words to the
song subscribe right now hitler ties buy
a song you ain't watching for Shaitaan
you watch the weight you put off good
I'll do it got my head on the ground and
my knees on the floor and the devil my
aiready telling me to trade it for the
world
don't say tomorrow do it now
Islam is the truth back here on the Deen
show with the director of care Chicago
and we're talking about some of the
things that you guys are involved in and
defending the civil civil liberties of
the American Muslims living here and we
talked about you know I mentioned that
we need to be proactive in helping
people to understand really what Muslims
are about Islam not to be shelter
somewhere away and not to be ashamed
we're we're many of us now are not you
know immigrants we've been here born
here I'm an American Muslim and then my
next question is when you see I
mentioned that you've been on CNN Fox
News and all the major networks out
there but how do you feel when they
bring on so-called experts of Islam that
don't really represent Islam some
extreme elements and they'll end up you
know having some ignorant Muslims out
there you know really extreme they'll
have these pictures out there saying
behead those that don't accept Islam
really ignorant statements doing
ignorant things but they take them they
don't bring our guests that we've had on
the Deen show who've truly you know
express what is Lomb is about you know
showing the facts not the fiction but
they bring on someone like for instance
what do you think about that well that's
what we call bias and it's what we call
selectivity and it's what we call cell
phone
fulfilling prophecy in other words if
you go with the scientific methods which
is the way truth is searched in this
dunya you basically start with a
question you don't have any preconceived
notions of the answer you scour your
subject matter you research it and
you're ready for any answer to know the
truth but in the method that you
described I already know what I want I
already know the answer so now I'm just
cherry picking evidence to support my
perspective it doesn't mean the evidence
isn't there it doesn't mean they're
making up these extremists because they
always tell us am I making this up it's
true it's there it's right there am i
lying no I'm not lying cause it's true
right but then we say look you're
cherry-picking this evidence you're not
lying about it but by omitting the other
evidence that points in the other
direction which is in fact the majority
evidence you are lying by omission by
being selective you're denying the
realities out there so people like these
extremists that you know we just saw in
the video and others they're rejected by
the mainstream you saw the uncles and
the uncles are not even as progressive
as some of the younger we're going to
I'm going to show this clip now so
people can see what actually you're
talking about right are they're going to
show the Muslims extremist out
[Music]
so as we saw you know these uncle's who
are often accused of being regressive
and old country and fathers
fresh-off-the-boat you know they have
the presence of mind and the
understanding of the religion and I
don't mean to sound condescending I
actually think very highly of them but
unfortunately that's the stereotype
right but even there they're actually
pushing this guy out and saying we don't
want you they can't get the hell out of
you we don't believe in what you have to
offer us and we believe that you are not
following the true path of his slap yeah
so that's something very important for
Americans and others others to
understand is that mainstream Muslims
mainstream Islamic society rejects
fundamentalism that is extremist that is
radical that is violent that is
basically against the grain of the
prophetic tradition of Muhammad
sallallaahu a southern piece of
breathing lessons be upon him which
preached love and kindness and mercy and
compassion and justice no doubt about it
justice is a big part of it but within
the bounds of how to pursue justice you
can't commit injustice in order to bring
about justice
you can't kill innocent people in order
to avenge or to bring about justice for
other innocent people it doesn't work
that way that's not a basis lamech way
that's just been being vengeful and
Islam is not a vengeful religion it's a
religion of mercy and compassion and
thoughtfulness yeah tell us that we've
seen many horrific acts against Muslims
you know the cab driver got is his
throat slit we see my mosque being
vandalized people who want to open up
places of worship they just want to
worship like Jesus worship they want to
put their head on the ground and prayed
only to God to the creator those are
that's what a much it is and people are
having high you know they're putting the
other meetings come coming down and you
know hard on people were trying to do
this you know what what are what what
can we do now also for to protect our
civil civil liberties to get involved
you know to make a positive change and
to protect ourselves from being the
victims well we've identified the
problem and what you just described now
is the consequence of the problem which
is selectivity so when people only see
the negative when they only see this guy
that we just saw and others like him
when they only see the terrorist that's
how they react those with a violent
tendency unfortunately you know the
attack people they commit assault even
if not that they may just you know
words of bigotry or hatred or commit
acts of discrimination that's a
consequence of the selectivity of only
seeing the negative and reacting to it
so part of the solution then is to
expand the horizons of the information
that's out there and present the
mainstream you know the other
information the evidence that goes
against you know this minority cell it's
you know selection that they're only
looking at and we're talking again about
our own lives we don't need to engage in
a PR campaign which mean that's
something we just need to be able to
showcase our own communities our own
history our own legacy our own reality
our own modern you know times and
communities today to show the wealth the
depth the breadth you know the richness
the fastest the diversity of this
community that isn't monolithic that
isn't just one big blob of the same
thing that has much more good than it
has bad and that's why slam is so
prevalent in the world today unless you
want to believe that human beings by
nature are stupid it would be hard for
you to believe that 2 billion of them
can choose a religion that is a work of
violence or preaching violence and
hatred I mean to milk 2 billion people
this isn't 200 people yeah you know how
did these people from China
- Mira tanya - you know Spain - America
Canada Australia Brazil all over the
world Middle East Africa you know how
did all these people with all their
diverse experiences you know their
genetic you know differences etc arrive
at the same conclusion that this
religion is a good religion for them
it's not because they're violent and
hateful and because they you know
they're psychologically disturbed to the
contrary it's because they're seeking
peace and they found peace in Islam
that's my story that's your story Eddie
that's probably the story of many
Muslims watching today who follow its
land they found peace in this religion
so that's the message we need to bring
out is what is a slant and why do we
follow Islam because it brings us inner
peace raises inner peace definitely and
I like to have a gift for you thank you
it's our film dunya to Deen and so we
thank you for you know all the the
audience I'm sure really it was exciting
having you with us they have so much
that was someone we only scratched the
surface hopefully God willing we can
have
back again in the future yeah we're not
far we can always pop in that definitely
thank you very much thanks Eddie thank
you Lakes song and that was the director
of care Chicago Ahmed here on the Dean
show thank you for tuning in
well let me just one more time this is
what we did well this is what we're
doing in a community before my life now
you saw that we're kicking them out
we're kicking them out Islam is not
about extremism and if you want to learn
more on the subjects of jihad or
terrorism go to the Deen show calm and
open your mind open your mind and read
and study we've done plenty of shows on
these topics but now you got to get
beyond that really look at the basic
teachings fundamental teachings of what
this way of life
this way of life that was brought by
Jesus Moses Abraham came with this
message of peace peace acquired by
submission to the will of the creator
doing the beautiful things that God
Almighty the crater's told us to do and
we're gonna have a program called faces
of terrorism that will go a little more
deep for the people who are still stuck
on this is really to get our perspective
we're gonna post it on Facebook you can
like us there also follow us on Twitter
and visit us here at the D show com
every week we're here with another
exciting episode until next time peace
be with you
[Music]
if I'm honest I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
Allah is by my side I am Not Afraid to
stay